make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this
is rob and initially i didn't plan to
cover this
this soon but once i got into issue
number 27 i was like okay i'm gonna go
ahead and just cover
this first part now and then we'll just
cover it as it gets released and so the
next one won't be out until september
16th
right so we have a little bit before the
next issue gets released but
then beyond basically comes in the
aftermath of venom island and venom
island wasn't overly important right i
mean it had a couple things that were
kind of important to it but if anything
it was probably like an epilogue to
absolute carnage the cool thing about
venom beyond
is this is actually a really great
jumping on point if you really want to
right like
all you really have to do is search for
like dylan like do a quick little thing
on dylan and then that's it right
that's really all you need and so the
the really two big important things that
came out of venom island
is that one eddie brock was offered
membership to the to the avengers but
doesn't really seem to have joined yet
and
two he basically told the avengers about
the coming of null right so that sets up
the whole like null arriving on earth
event so at the very least the heroes
are aware now something that goes into
venom beyond with this initial instance
we basically pick up with this guy
basically fleeing for his life right
just essentially running and ultimately
he bumps into eddie brock now the crazy
thing about this
is the guy you know eddie's like dude
what's what's going on man is everything
cool and the guy's like yeah man
something's chasing after me and he's
like oh that oh here's the deal you're a
hard man to find
like i just had that guy go after you i
have my symbiote attack you to basically
chase you here so that i could catch you
right so literally setting up a trap
and it's pretty cool to see eddie brock
using venom in that capacity the crazy
thing about this though is that
basically he tells this guy
you can lie to me or you can live right
but you can't do both so tell me the
truth about what i want to know about a
particular location right eddie's eddie
brock's basically trying to track down
a particular warehouse now from there he
ends up traveling with dylan and when he
and dylan arrive
at this location uh it's kind of this
little bit of a joke in the sense that
dylan's like it's like like i don't
understand like why are we looking for a
warehouse right like nothing cool ever
happens in a warehouse and eddie's
response is no man warehouses are the
coolest place to go to right if you want
if you want to see some stuff happen
warehouses is where you go the other
part of this is that there's a kind of
conversation with regards to
trying to more or less fix dylan and the
idea is that eddie never really wanted
this kind of life for dylan now a bit of
an explanation here for those of you
guys who are are new to this whole thing
so one of the things we discovered in
absolute carnage in the events leading
up to it
is that dylan is the son of eddie brock
right we discovered that
in the venom line of comics before the
events of absolute carnage but at that
point in time when dylan was first
introduced there seemed to be something
about him
right donnie kate's didn't initially
come out and say what it was but we knew
there was kind of something going on
with it the reality of dylan is of
course he's the biological child of
eddie brock and eddie's uh really former
wife
and weighing and of course anne wayne
was known as she venom at one point and
had long since been dead but before she
died
she handed dylan over to eddie's father
and he'd been raised really in like an
abusive way until eddie discovered him
and then took him under his wing but the
idea here is that
dylan is basically the result of a
symbiote taken on a human form
he's kind of the opposite of what we
normally expect and the idea behind
dylan and we'll get more into this when
we cover the web of venom one shot with
regards to dylan himself is that he can
actually control symbiotes right we know
that from the events of absolute carnage
that a symbiote can basically be
dominated and controlled by dylan
whether it wants to be or not so he has
that kind of unique power going for him
he can sense symbiotes different things
like that and so eddie never really
wanted him to have this kind of life and
so what they're doing is basically
tracking down a location where uh where
a person can essentially undo this or
the very least give dylan the kind of
control over his powers that he's
looking for to give him some semblance
of a normal life and so what we have
going on while while venom
and dylan are traveling to this location
we have a character named
virus now virus is a character that we
don't know anything about
but the cool thing is he almost looks
like punisher meets uh meets war machine
meets like iron man and the cool thing
about it is that if you look at the way
his his
eyes are more or less spray-painted on
his face it looks like the spawn design
which is
really cool right so uh whatever this
guy is because we don't really know
anything about him whoever this guy is
is basically chasing after eddie brock
right he's he's constantly chasing eddie
and the cool thing is that once they
arrive at this warehouse and then eddie
kind of freaks out and smashes down the
door you end up finding the maker now
the the strange thing about this is we
know the two of them are kind of working
together but immediately the venom
symbiote starts hitting the eddy along
with dylan and saying something's not
right here something's wrong the simeone
himself
should be able to detect the maker right
like recognize him as an object that's
there as a being that's there
dylan should be able to do the same
thing but the problem is that both the
venom symbiote
and dylan as far as they're aware
there's nothing there right they can
physically see him but they can't
actually detect him
it seems like something's off and so
whatever it is basically seems to kind
of be
cloaking or clouding the existence of
maker to a degree and that's what's kind
of nuts
because you see this sort of
conversation going on between uh eddie
brock and the maker and it's kind of
like this idea of hitting it like
codexes and so on what we saw during the
events of absolute carnage but at the
end of the day it always seemed like the
maker had this kind of nefarious plan
against eddie and the reality is what we
know about the maker is he's just trying
to return back to his native universe
right trying to get back to the ultimate
universe we know there's also another
plot going on with this character we
don't have a whole lot of information on
but what we also end up learning here is
that the reason why the venom symbiote
and and dylan cannot detect maker is
because maker is wearing the ultimate
universe version of the venom suit now
for those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with that in the ultimate universe
unlike the main marvel universe the
symbiote was engineered
but the reason why the ultimate universe
symbiote matters so much is because the
main marvel universe symbiote to a
degree was static
insofar as it had a set of abilities and
those abilities couldn't really be
modified but with the maker and having a
a engineered symbiote it means it can be
changed on a whim
you can do anything with it right you
can adjust its powers you can do all
kinds of stuff it's just adjusting code
and so because of that it basically
overpowers eddie brock and actually
knocks him out of his own symbiote which
is a pretty cool display of power and
the venom submit of course reconstitutes
itself to eddie but then it's just kind
of like okay
uh what in the world is going on here
right like we've got to find a way to be
able to topple this guy but the symbiote
he has is a lot more powerful than our
own the funny thing is that in the
middle of all this
virus arrives right and virus shows up
and just starts attacking everybody
right it's going after venom but it
attacks whatever
what he perceives to be everybody who's
in the way and it's kind of cool because
virus basically has like anti-symbiotic
you know weaponry to a degree but the
other thing here
is that eddie doesn't know who who this
is and virus keeps talking about how
eddie ruined his life right how he
ruined his life he screwed things up and
he's just trying to get back at him for
this right so he really seems to be more
of a revenge character the other part is
that virus is basically using what
amounts to a hodgepodge setup all the
technology he has
right the pumpkin bombs and the green
goblins collider this is all old stuff
right these are things that he just
seemed to have collected from like what
amounts to superhero junkyards and
different things like that he's not
professionally backed right he's not
funded by any real money he's just a guy
who took some stuff and now he's doing
things so
one this shows that he's operating of
his own accord and two it shows the guys
knows
the guy knows what he's doing in terms
of understanding how this technology and
how this equipment works
and so in the middle of this great big
huge conflict he ends up basically
throwing one of the pumpkin bombs at a
portal that the maker had set up and the
portal immediately activates now the
maker
gets yanked through but so does dylan
and venom right and so the result of
this is that you basically have the
maker who shows back
up in the ultimate universe but the
whole place is trashed right everything
seems to have been totally destroyed now
we know the ultimate universe had been
back for a long time
we knew that from a few teasers that we
got here and there but it wasn't
officially returned until brian michael
bendis wrote spider-man 2 and then left
for dc comics so the ultimate universe
has been there for a little while
marvel has included it from time to time
and i think it's actually a pretty big
deal here that marvel's actually
focusing on the ultimate universe
the idea was that in the aftermath of
bendis leaving marvel seems to have just
kind of like clean slated everything
that bendis did
any of the work that bendis had going on
marvel either undid it or pretended like
it didn't exist but the fact that it's
being being put out here now as a thing
that does exist and marvel editorial
seems to be okay with it really points
to the fact that the ultimate universe
is going to be returning in a big way
the other part of this is that with the
portal having been activated before the
maker was yanked through
he basically said we're gonna end up
being scattered across different
dimensions
you end up having eddie brock and dylan
who arrive in what seems to be a totally
different reality than where the maker
ended up in and we don't really know
much about this place in fact it's not
really even given to us as a numerical
designation instead we just kind of have
this flag that's flying with a
particular symbol which looks
reminiscent of the house of m
but it's basically one of these things
where the the venom symbiote and really
eddie brock kind of begin to comment on
some of the things that can happen now
either by virtue of the events of
absolute carnage of what the what the
the venom symbiote has learned along the
way the cool thing is that you end up
having this this scenario where you're
basically explaining that like the venom
symbiote can do a lot more than it used
to where the venom symbiote was able to
dodge spider-man spider-sense and it had
like all the abilities of spider-man
with like a few enhancements you know
increased strength different things like
that that now the venom symbiote can do
things like predict earthquakes it can
feel the presence of danger from like
miles away so like spider-man
spider-sense totally amped up it can
basically see in the dark it can breathe
underwater it can talk in space it can
heal almost any wound right so like the
venom symbiote it's kind of been
blown up in terms of its abilities these
abilities have kind of been expanded on
the ones that were established before
have been added by some of the ones that
we've listed now because what you have
here is the venom symbiote basically
telling eddie there's a hive mind on
this planet right this planet
seems to be ruled by symbiotes i don't
really know i'm trying to understand
what's going on here but dylan is almost
kind of in the same boat right
it's almost confusing and it's almost a
bit baffling because he has this massive
influx of all this information from what
seems to be this venom hive mind
all flowing into dylan himself as well
as the symbiote now of course as soon as
they arrive
virus is right back at it again right
virus is coming right back at them and i
love the way that donnie cates does this
because the worst thing he could have
done was to throw virus away not really
throw him away but to say like he
doesn't appear here he didn't follow
them the reason why this matters is
because what it shows is that whatever
vendetta this virus guy has
is intense and he will chase after eddie
brock no matter where he goes in order
to find him the other part of this is
that there didn't really
seem to be any indication that if a
person passed through the portal then
unless they
intended to go to a particular place
then they would end up somewhere in
particular instead he would just kind of
be scattered indiscriminately right and
so what this seems to indicate
is that whether by his own intelligence
or some techno technology that he has at
his disposal that virus was able to kind
of chart the portal more or less or we
can kind of assume uh the multiverse to
a degree and basically chase down eddie
brock and then find out where he's at
right and then locate him and then
travel to that particular universe which
is no small feat the only people that
we've seen to be able to do that in
marvel comics up to this point
are multiversal characters like you know
the molecule man owen reese or maybe
somebody like
uh like protege or somebody you know who
could basically copy anybody else's
powers it's kind of a big deal right
this is kind of an ability reserved for
super powerful beings or those with
sufficient technology and so this fight
between the two
is pretty cut throat because you
basically end up having you know virus
basically you know
seeming that he's either gonna go after
eddie brock's son or basically take out
eddie brock first and then go after
dylan regardless of the circumstance
because virus is basically out to kill
eddie once eddie gets out of view of his
son then it's kind of like okay the
battle's on like you know i won't kill
anybody in front of my son but i'll do
it when he's not there
right and so they're basically just kind
of fighting to the death here and again
this is what's kind of crazy is because
of the fact that there's so much
information coming in
from like all these symbiotes that are
basically around this world that venom
can't really
focus it's almost like being surrounded
by just a blaring horn
and then trying to focus on yourself
right it's difficult to do like this
horn almost keeps you distracted
all the time it does allow the symbiote
to basically pop some wings like we've
seen it do before
and then grant him you know the ability
to fly and kind of continue the attack
going on with virus the other thing that
we're kind of given here
is is the symbiote developing a sort of
new power in the sense that what it can
do is it can basically absorb the uh the
the energies that are sent out the the
attacks that are sent out by virus and
then channel them back at him again
right so kind of like the power of
bishop now the reason why i call this
video
venom's new god powers is because this
is one of these circumstances we talked
about
so many times before in marvel comics
where a character has an existing set of
powers and then those powers will be
modified or new powers will be added to
that character and then will never be
given an upper limit
this is significant because venom's
ability to control energy and then throw
it back
at somebody is what puts it puts beings
like vulcan for example into the omega
level category
if you can channel somebody's energy
back at them you can control that energy
and if you can control that energy you
can do all kinds of things with it you
can turn it into a different form of
energy you can use it to bolster
yourself to
to enhance yourself plus the other part
that's given here is that eddie seems to
be able to hold on to it right so if
somebody like iron man shot venom with
the repulsor blast then he could
basically absorb that energy and then
hold it and potentially use it to
improve his own powers
that's why this is important that's why
i call it that because this is the kind
of beginning stages
of having every eddie brock's powers
amplified and what you're probably going
to see
is that as null gets closer and as we
get closer to the conflict where null
arrives on earth that that major story
arc that marvel's going to do you're
going to see a situation whereby
eddie's powers are going to be amplified
so they can match and basically go
toe-to-toe with null and null
is in himself a god-like character and
so with that being the case
these are basically eddie's new god
powers i don't really see these powers
changing insofar
as new power is being added but i do see
them being amped up
not having to breathe in space you know
being able to talk in space not having
to breathe underwater being able to take
the energy of those and channel it back
at them that's matter manipulation
franklin richards does that just in the
most extreme degree i'm not saying that
you know venom is going to become like a
universal reality warping character but
what i am saying is his powers are going
to be amped up in a pretty
extreme way so again that's what makes
this so cool and so with dylan basically
calling out for aid you know in the
middle of this whole thing once virus is
basically dealt with when venom gets
back there
you end up seeing a kind of venomized
avengers team right and i say venomized
because they're all basically wearing
venom
venom costumes right like all the
costumes they have have the venom marker
on it right with it's thor with his
captain america
iron man black widow which i think is
especially ironic right because
the black widow spider is a type of
spider and now she's a venom spider
whatever that is
black panther seems to be the exact same
way all the super superheroes here are
venomized superheroes now it's not the
first time we've seen that but eddie
initially
tries to rationalize with him right
because in his mind it may not
necessarily be that they're in a
different dimension so much as they've
been sent forward through time but with
him talking to these guys and saying
look cap steve like it's me it's it's
eddie brock like you know who i am
they're like we don't know who you are
right but put the symbiote down and put
your hands on your head and with eddie
brock of course saying like
no like not really doing that that leads
to an assault that basically leads to
to virus launching an attack against
eddie and then from there you end up
having virus
going against the venomized superheroes
now this is going to be a testament to
how powerful virus is because it's one
thing to go against venom it's another
to go to
go through a group of superheroes that
are complimented by the power of venom
and i say compliment it because when you
have black panther who presumably has
the powers that were given to him by
bass right so enhanced strength speed
agility so on and so forth those powers
are amplified by the venom symbiote
assuming that we're talking about a
one-to-one ratio between what the venom
symbiote powers are in the main marvel
universe and what the powers are here
are you talking about captain america
who's basically just a guy
there's really nothing special about him
getting the venom symbiote and then in
turn like
thor you know that kind of a thing his
power is being augmented and amplified
you're really talking about some heavy
hitters here who are even stronger for
the symbiotes they have
and so with that being the case you end
up finding out that one of the ways in
which virus gets the upper hand while
you have eddie rock basically fleeing
one of the ways in which virus gets the
upper hand on these uh on these
symbiotes is by using
symbiote disruption technology using a
combination of what seems to be sound
waves and fire and using them to blast
captain america but what you end up
learning here is that much like the
venom semi that we see in the main
marvel universe
these guys can reconstitute themselves
you know you destroy them and it blows a
piece of the symbiote off but it just
reforms it restructures which makes them
wildly difficult to kill the other part
of this is that using anti-symbiote
technology is illegal within this
reality right on this earth and so of
course
virus being overpowered is taken into
custody from there you end up following
eddie and you end up following dylan and
it's kind of like okay like
what in the world is going on here right
we're obviously not in our own universe
right we're not in the the universe that
we came from we're in some other place
what in the heck is happening here and
as they're making their way through
there's suddenly a giant blinding
flashing light now the other now we kind
of switch back to what's called
the hive which seems to be the base of
operations for these various avengers
who are being led
by a particular guy basically known as
the codex we don't really know who this
guy is and we're not really shown any
information or shown any indication of
who this guy is instead he's basically
the guy running the show but then you
end up having
the helmet of virus being removed we
don't find out who he is instead
it's just this guy basically saying i
have no idea who this guy is i don't
know who this
i've never ever heard of this guy so the
implication seems to be he's a totally
new character in marvel he's not a
character that we know of he's not
somebody who
who we've seen before who was screwed
over by eddie and basically made his
return
but the other cool thing here is that
with eddie and and and dylan kind of on
the run
they're met by what's basically the
rebellion right a group of these
individuals who were trying to face off
and destroy these various symbiote
forces right so obviously the symbiotes
conquered the world at some point we
just don't know how far reaching this is
but what we end up basically seeing here
is this rebellion is led by a new agent
venom the agent venom of this reality is
a wholly new person and i gotta tell you
guys
this agent venom looks kind of cool i'm
a little on the fence about it though if
i'm being honest
because i liked the original asian venom
costume i liked the way the original
costume looked i love the original
costume but i'm also kind of a fan of
this i think it's kind of cool i think
it's a little too bulky but i think it's
kind of cool
and so with that being the case eddie's
kind of like okay what's going on here
who are you what are you talking about
with rebellion and all that kind of
stuff and they're like well first we
need some we need some questions
answered right we need to know who you
are and he basically says like
my name is eddie brock and this is my
son dylan and then this person this this
helmet basically comes off of
of agent venom we end up finding of
course these are basically humans that
are rebelling against the symbiotes and
not only is this agent venom a human
it's actually
the alternate reality version of ann
weighing this is the former wife
and mother of dylan who seems to have
survived whatever it is that was going
on here with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you